[Music]
see what being a my Buble fan is one of
the best parts of my life I have been to
seven of microblaze concerts I have all
of his albums I'm so excited to be here
at Warner brother records to see some of
the rare memorabilia that has been a
part of Michaels career throughout the
years and we're gonna get to actually do
kind of like a sound test in a Chevy
Malibu and listen to something new
before anybody else like that's just
insane I mean I think your fans are an
extension of everything that you do I
believe that if your song doesn't
connect emotionally with those people
you're gonna be alone singing in your
bathroom here with a hairbrush
you know no matter what producer you
work with a 1 million dollar studio
you're at when something is done the
first thing you do is go into the
parking lot and listen because you know
if you're lucky enough for your song
come out and hit the radio waves that
everyone else is gonna hear it that way
there all right so right now Lorne is
actually waiting downstairs and she has
absolutely no idea that I'm gonna
surprise her so this could be really
really cool hey I was so excited to
surprise you how are you this is the
reaction I was hoping for deep sadness
it's nice to to you know what we're
gonna do we're gonna go to the car and
I'm going to play you a new track from
the record no way yeah do that
I'm so ready so this is my take on one
of the great great standards and so what
you're about to hear is pretty much us
just doing what we love I'm trying to
bring this song to life are you ready
kid I'm ready here we go
[Music]
[Music]
just like swing dance in the car that's
it talks like you like it I love it kind
of just like yours does
[Music]